se calienta la carrera para llegar al
número 10 de Downey Street y a pesar de
los escándalos que los salpican el
nombre de Boris Johnson está nuevamente
sobre la mesa el ex Primer Ministro es
uno de los favoritos para reemplazar la
efímeraliss Aunque competirá Connect y
Penny Morgan Esta última ya confirmó sus
intenciones
el popular Secretario de Defensa ven
Wallace otro de los que podría haberse
presentado le dio su respaldo a Johnson
tenemos que pensar en esa cuestión de
legitimidad que el público se estará
preguntando y también sobre quién podría
ganar las próximas elecciones Así que ya
sabes que en este momento me inclinaría
por Boris Johnson tras los estragos del
Party Gate no es una idea que todos los
británicos respalden la oposición
laborista que lidera en las encuestas
vuelve a pedir que se llame a elecciones
generales mientras arremete contra
Johnson
Bueno me acuerdo que hace solo tres
meses Boris Johnson dejó el cargo porque
la mayoría de los que le servían en su
primera línea habían declarado que no
era apto para el cargo
en la calle el Primer Ministro tampoco
parece encontrar respaldo allá no creo
que deban traer de vuelta a Boris
Johnson creo que están asumiendo que
ganará las próximas elecciones porque lo
hizo muy bien en las últimas pero muchas
cosas han cambiado desde entonces Y creo
que ha demostrado una total falta de
integridad
en 2019 Johnson fue la cara del voto del
brexit y logró una aplastante victoria
para los conservadores en estos momentos
de incertidumbre y de falta de Unión
política entre los Stories Boris Johnson
podría convertirse en la tabla de
salvación del partido pero en caso de
volver se enfrentaría no solo a los
fantasmas de sus escándalos políticos
sino a una economía tambaleante